peer to peer or people to people this is
what the web is becoming more and more
you have to think what are the people
needs and not what are the organization
what how is your granese organizations
structured because at the end of the day
the citizen me I don't care how you are
structured I want to find the right
information faster means more velocity
means more reactivity means more real
time means more localization people will
want information faster quicker now dig
hong kong le monde will connect san
ramon domain japoni on foot to let me
open a photo villalpando photo monetary
cuter shirt wit a hermitage of his book
chippewa a certain number 32 dude on a
quest regalo de Philippa existing local
more varied everyone pretty much what if
I've had to say I rent on Twitter
including now as of yesterday and
Nicolas Sarkozy which is huge so this
doesn't mean that the Arab Spring is a
web two point on phenomena or that
technology or Twitter or Facebook made
it happen it means just that these
technology tools related pieces that
were previously loosely connected for
the future for us is the better the
better system of sentiment tracking
because this is a great sorcerer
information for everyone la mobilization
Decepticon Co Co Co Co Co may final
moe-san appeared on packed otra musio
sis necio legion como le prix receptive
haces ando con Hakim oh oh ma sanga una
razón followers e said so retweet avec
in Winnipeg sank retweet poo in a treat
all of you AHA pavo see Elena president
Lucille O'Leary State of the Union
speech attempt okokokokok hey dolly
media pasco prefer freaking van con avec
des proposition II don't say ideas
natural male members kiss if a demoniac
reason poor Todd media dicen que bajas
noche de boku mo fed a comprar el
desastre palmilla false economy
if you look for example at Twitter feeds
from the institution's they too formal I
mean it's too it's too not not always
the official ones it's too it's too
difficult for people to sort of relate
to them to be honest I mean EU policies
to most people is exceptionally boring I
think what we've managed to successfully
do at least in English is that we
managed to sort of find a way to
communicate these issues on arranged in
a range of different hue policy areas in
a way that actually makes sense we
cannot think that the user would
understand or the difficult was that we
use within the system we must they must
be based on the user's reality and the
users words citizens and businesses they
don't really care who is the sender of
it they just need to know what is it for
what does it mean to me and if we need
to do some knowledge sharing with you do
it backstage people are saying we have
our ICT within our organizations we have
all these American but we have nothing
within the Netherlands to or within
government to work together between
different organizations and agencies so
that's why I thought I start my own sort
of a platform social networking platform
it which is called a player which is a
logical name in touch but I'll just call
it government square because that's what
literal is GovLoop is a very very simple
mission it's all about making government
awesome in the current climate where I
guess the the public perception is that
government then I have sort of put it
nicely as a little bit dull and boring
public bodies to really be aware that
social media do you have rules and we do
not do not do need to adapt to these
rules and these rules are about
transparency reciprocity they are about
authenticity and openness the
applications and digital TV which is
connected to internet is I think the
next next big platform for us because
those people who are not visiting our
website or Facebook they are behind TV
transaction is an e service at self
service it is only open for
and euros in transaction costs compared
to receiving a male compared to personal
services that is a huge business case
here if you use Facebook you have many
ways of using it you can use it in a
very confidential way as well the
privacy setting you do corresponding to
the group there are many many
interesting topics we have heard of
during the day for example that it was
said again and again about citizens this
is about citizens these are not about
technology of course we know it but we
are not always acting as if we
understand it